let's talk about the green New Deal
legislation that is now out co-sponsored
by congresswoman Alexandria Casio Cortez
in the house and by Senator Ed Markey in
the Senate the idea of a green new deal
is we want to deal with two major issues
climate change and economic inequality
New Deal refers to Franklin Delano
Roosevelt in the post-world War two ERA
stimulus infrastructure job creation and
the idea of a green new deal is to do
another New Deal but one that takes into
account everything we know about climate
change in the environment so AOC and
Markey put out a 14-page resolution the
right goes bonkers saying there's no
details this is pie in the sky it can
never be done it's impractical we've got
no way to pay for it it doesn't make any
sense even Nancy Pelosi is being careful
about the green New Deal saying it's an
enthusiastic idea and that's good but
she's also kind of laughing it off by
calling it the green dream so right away
the main thing is is this a step-by-step
list of policies with a guide as to how
to implement them and how to pay for
them the answer is no is it just a list
of things which would be nice with no
other relevance no is this 14 page
proposal meant to become the law not
really but that doesn't mean that it
can't be impactful so what I'm going to
tell you first is what the green New
Deal wants to do now and then I'll tell
you where I think Democrats may be going
wrong with this but that doesn't mean
that it's a bad proposal okay but this
green New Deal is a list of goals and
some of them are vague some of them are
unrealistic in terms of their timing but
it's a really important list of what
should be priorities for any serious
progressive candidates at this point
everybody should read it before
commenting it's only 14 pages and the
way they do these resolutions the
margins are gigantic like you would
never be allowed to turn this in as a
school paper it's only like half the
width of the page because it's so narrow
so there's very little text
the page the first two pages just kind
of frame the situation so it's very
little actual text every single one of
you should look at it
the proposal gives a ten year time
horizon to do the following number one
get to net zero greenhouse gas emissions
with 100 percent of power demand through
clean renewable zero emission energy
sources okay yeah it's not realistic
doing it in 10 years while at the same
time upgrading all existing buildings in
the United States to the most modern
standard it's extraordinary
excuse me extraordinarily unlikely you'd
be able to do that in ten years but this
is actually exactly what the goal should
be creating millions of jobs is a goal
okay that's great we should say more
about how investing in infrastructure
but sustainably fine securing clean air
water climate resiliency healthy food
access to nature and a sustainable
environment fantastic it's short on the
details but we'll get to that promoting
justice and equity by stopping and
preventing oppressions of all kinds I
like it but you've got to be more
specific about exactly what you're
talking about and hopefully at some
point we will see that there's a lot of
even more vague ideas like for example
quote building a more sustainable food
system that ensures universal access to
healthy food that sounds good but we've
got to talk about the specifics of what
we mean by that investing in high-speed
rail and public transit absolutely but
we're gonna have to flesh out how there
are some more specific items like
cleaning up hazardous waste and
abandoned sites that are toxic at this
point we should do it of course the most
important thing about this document
though for me is the timing because it's
a totally fair criticism that this
doesn't lay out exactly how you do these
things although that's not uncommon in
these initial proposals it's a fair
criticism that it doesn't outline how to
pay for it that's also common it's very
common that when you get a proposal in
the House or Senate the proposal says
what you want to do you separately
outline how it would be paid for in an
appropriations bill
it's a fair critique but that's commonly
how these things work
the most important thing about this
document is that with the Democratic
primary ramping up no 2020 Democrat has
straight-up backed away from it you do
have some Democrats paint playing a
little coy with it like Elizabeth Warren
said she's into it but when she was
asked what specifically do you support
in it she didn't say cory booker i
forget exactly what he said about it but
it was again this kind of more timid
support of it but if you if at this
point you're running in 2020 is a
democrat and you say i am against the
bill that's a real problem and that's a
good thing and that's one of the most
important things that this bill that
this proposal actually does now we do
need to figure out a path to doing it
and that's a really important thing and
what we're already running into is that
you have a number of people on the Left
making strategic mistakes like for
example i saw an adviser to alexandria
Cascio cortez on the tucker carlson show
I apologize that I forget his name I
believe is a Cornell University law
professor and a lot of the defenses that
he issued were arguing that Tucker had
merely misunderstood the proposal and
what aoc tweeted and said about it and
some of the denials were really not
particularly believable I think that
that's a mistake
I think the idea that that would much
better serve the left would be to be
completely on the same page that listen
it doesn't say how we pay for it that's
normal
separately we're going to put out a
proposal for how to pay for it that's
what Bernie did with Medicare for all
and then with how to pay for it when
they say a lot of these things are too
ambitious you respond and you say these
are the goals let's see how much of it
we can actually get done it's a really
bad idea in my estimation to sort of
back away and play semantics games as
I've seen some people do that's why the
right ends up winning they say we're
gonna prioritize ending abortion as we
know it and tax cuts for everyone and
then they pass some restrictions on
abortion and then they cut taxes
written corporations but then they can
claim victory and they are putting
points up on the board and they end up
getting themselves reelected the left
should not fall into the game of saying
okay fine maybe we're not going to do it
in ten years maybe we would shoot for
fifty percent net zero
fifty percent of the way towards net
zero in fifteen years or something like
that that's a mistake that is a mistake
we should actually be taking a page from
the right here in terms of how to handle
the criticisms of this proposal I want
to hear from you i'm on instagram at
david pakman the show is on instagram at
david pakman show one of today's
sponsors pres about is offering you some
free stuff that I want to tell you about
spresso box is based in New York City
they help keep guys wardrobes fresh
without breaking the bank because when
you become a member of spresso box each
month you'll get a new box sent to your
door
filled with five or six stylish
hand-picked accessories and pieces of
clothing for men it includes high end
socks neckties really nice sunglasses
wallets watches bracelets high-quality
pens and hair combs it's really classy
stuff that makes it easy to put a little
more pop into your wardrobe without
having to spend a ton of money a
subscription is just twenty-five bucks a
month but your new box every single
month is guaranteed to have items with a
combined value of over a hundred dollars
a couple of the things I got are a
really nice money clip a pocket square
and some great socks go check out the
different things that they put in their
monthly boxes they have a lot of really
nice-looking stuff everyone in our
audience can get one month totally free
when you click the link underneath this
video and use the promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma N